so in the last video we talked about was
comparing pk's to ph's and using that to
determine whether or not particular
functional groups were protonated or
deprotonated in their acid form in their
base form so on and so forth so I
thought it would be helpful to go
through a particular example so I know
we haven't gone over amino acids just
yet but I've been talking about them a
lot and I figured out using an example
of an amino acid would be very very
useful so what I'm going to do here is
I'm going to draw aspartate which is an
acidic amino acid and I'm going to draw
it like this okay
now this what I'm drawing here is called
the Fischer projection okay and amino
acids going to have this carboxyl group
a hydrogen and this chiral carbon if you
recall back in the day chiral carbons
have four different substituents this
will be the amino group right and here's
going to be the sidechain um for a
sparked eight its side chain looks like
this it has a ch2 group and then a
carboxylic acid group okay so this is
specifically a Fischer projection of L
aspartate okay now I'm going to talk
about you know why the different TL and
D and that sort of stuff I'll go into
details about amino acids later
don't sweat it too much right now but
this is L aspartate and specifically
it's the Fischer projection okay again
don't sweat that too much right now
that's not the focus of this video so
what I wanted to mention is that there
this this aspartate that I've drawn here
has three functional groups that we are
going to consider import I'm going to
label them a B and C okay this this
right here this so a B and C they're all
ionizable groups ionizable
functional groups what on earth does
that mean that simply means they can
become ions okay now if you know in
organic chemistry right these are this
is a carboxylic acid group as is this
right this here is an amino group now we
all know that carboxylic acid groups are
aesthetic groups and amino groups you
should recall our basic groups right and
again the definition comes into play
acidic side chains or acidic functional
groups right
they are proton donors generally
speaking and basic side chains or basic
excuse me basic functional groups are
going to be good at accepting protons
okay so what I kind of already show you
right here and now um it's uh is the
following let me actually draw this out
for you so so if this is an acidic group
we can depict this as our carboxyl group
so the are just represents some carbon
chain right so it's the same thing here
they're both carboxylic groups
carboxylic acid groups so if this is any
acid then it's acid dissociation the
equation will look like this so if this
is an acid and this is proton it's going
to donate a proton correct this is an
acid and what's going to be left is our
Co OH - okay
so what's going on here this is the acid
this is the conjugate base okay now so
we drew it out like that because here a
and C write these two carboxylic acid
groups are in their acidic form right
there protonated so they're going to act
as acids I mean if they are going to act
like asses this is how they would do it
right Bo this here this amino group is
not protonated right so it's a it's a
basic group it can accept the proton
right so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to draw that out like this right
if we have an amino group right some R
and H - okay and it picks up a proton
it'll go and become our nh3 plus alright
that's a plus charge there is circle
this - here okay so now this is its acid
form this is the acid form this is the
base form so you probably understand why
I drew it like this now is that I wanted
the acids this is I wanted these to be
written as acid dissociation equations
so this thing has a particular PKA and
this thing has particular PKA this these
are both acids and these are both the
conjugate bases right these are
protonated right they carry the proton
these are deprotonated they've lost
their protons so what I wanted to do
like I said I wanted to do a particular
practice problem involving these but
before I do that I want to just label
these really quickly right these are
both acids is the conjugate bases all
right so um now what what what's going
to happen is right is if these groups
right they're all going to have PK's
right because they can all be protonated
right so they can all exist in an acid
form but some are going to be stronger
acids and others I'm going to be weaker
so those that are stronger going to be
more willing to donate their protons and
exist in the base form and those that
are less they're not as good as acids
are going to exist in their acid form
right they're not going to donate their
proton so what I wanted to do was a like
I said a quick practice problem okay so
let's say they tell you the pKa of the
sidechain
the side chain carboxyl group of
aspartate which I'll abbreviate it as
ASP you'll learn all those abbreviations
in a later video ASP the PK have a side
chain carboxyl group of ASP or aspartate
is approximately 4.0 okay at a pH of 5
this label that says a part a what form
will predominate predominate base or
acid right knowledge so base or acid
charged or uncharged this might not make
sense just yet but it will in just a
moment hopefully oh goodness
let me fix that unchanged charged or
uncharged okay and the second part of
this question will be whoops that let's
get 13 with up B okay the second part
will be what percent will be an acid
form and what percent will be a base
form and in base form
all right so how do we do this what
we're going to use the
henderson-hasselbalch equation right so
let's let's get our green going right so
we can start doing these that using the
engine else Bloch equation just as is it
to recall
oh goodness of course I just said green
and I write in white okay so recall the
henderson-hasselbalch equation is pH is
equal to the pka plus the log of the
concentration of the base over the
concentration of the acid right so now
in our case right if we're talking about
this is asking about the sidechain
carboxyl group right and they're saying
that the pKa of it is 4.0 right so our
approximately so the sidechain of this R
should be this carboxyl group here is
the sidechain carboxyl group this is
called the Alpha carboxyl group and
again I'll go into details about that a
later video
this here they're saying that the pKa of
this this acid group is 4 okay they're
asking at a pH of 5 what what form will
predominate so base or acid charged or
uncharged this charged or uncharged
thing kind of doesn't make sense right
just yet maybe but or maybe it does who
knows but if they're asking about base
or acid that means they want us to find
this ratio right they give us these two
values we need to find this so let's go
ahead and do that let's solve for it so
if we want to get that this ratio by
itself let's let's just rearrange this
equation say pH minus PKA equals the log
of the concentration of the base over
the concentration of the acid and then
oops yeah that's correct sorry and we
want to get just the ratios with undo
that log so we're going to take the base
10 let me change the color to make that
a little bit clearer so we have to take
the base 10 this entire thing the pH
minus B K the base 10 of that log to
undo that okay and then what we're left
with
is the base to acid ratio the base to
acid ratio will be equal to ten to the
pH minus PKA okay so now all we need to
do is plug in these values so the base
to acid ratio will equal 10 to the pH
which is 5 and our PKA is 4 so 10 to the
1 right so so that means and 10 to the 1
is 10 right so what does that mean I
don't want to write it just as 10 right
although the base to acid ratio is 10
it's not just 10 right it's 10 to 1 for
every one species everyone a base excuse
me every species existing in the base
form right there for every 10 of them
there's gonna be one in the acid form
conversely right if for every one
existing in the acid form there gonna be
one of the bit or ten in the base of our
so what what does that mean right what
are we talking about well this group
right this is a carboxyl group so it's
as a dissociation equation looks like
this right so what's the basin what's
the acid well in our case this is the
conjugate base and this is the conjugate
acid so we know then that there's going
to be 10 looking like this for every one
that looks like this protonated I hope
that makes sense that means at a pH of 5
we would expect to see more in the base
form than we would in the acid form
right because there's 10 in the base
form for everyone in the acid form so
the answer to part a right the first
part of Part A the spacer acid the base
base form predominates right so let's
write that in red since the dark answer
okay so base form predominates right now
also ask the charged or uncharged which
form predominates well the base form
predominates right is that charged or
uncharged well it's carrying that
negative charge there right this
protonated group is is uncharged right
so the base form predominates right and
the charged form predominates right now
it's not always the case of the base
form is is charged for instance in the
case of an amino group all right if you
look up here the acid form is protonated
right and it carries that positive
charge whereas the base form does not
right so bear that in mind we're doing
problems involving amino groups versus
carboxyl groups okay so it's Part B here
says what percentage will be in the acid
form and what percentage will be in the
base form okay so well we know that
there's just a second let me note all
this all this was basically the artwork
for the Part A so let's do Part B so for
Part B Part B we want to know what
percentage will be in the acid form a
percentage of database for now this can
get a little bit tricky let's just think
about this for a second the percentage
just basically means for every hundred
right so we want to know about parts of
a whole well our ratio here tells us we
have 10 base for every one acid right so
that means a total if we just consider
this right this total we have 11 things
1111 parts right ten of which are base
one of which is an acid so if we think
about that if you want to find the
percentage that will be in the acid form
what we we do is we take the number of
acids oops let's do this in green sorry
right Oh what we'll do is we'll take the
number of acid so actually before I
write that the percent in the acid form
will equal the
number in the acid form right over the
total number of species right which will
be equal to the number of acid number in
the acid form plus the number in the
base form right and then we'll have that
fraction all we have to do is multiply
that by a hundred percent so if we do
that then we have the number in the acid
form will be one number in the acid form
here is one number in the base form is
ten so we have one oops
goodness gracious that's right the times
one hundred percent I always forget that
okay so times 100 percent here right so
is going to be one over eleven times one
hundred percent and we'll get um nine
point one percent right so that's for
the acid right so if you want to find in
the base form all we have to do is take
this number oh it's the terrible box if
though if it if there are some of the
acid form in our some in the base form
here we're saying that nine point one
percent are in the acid form well the
rest have to be in the base form right
so then the percent in the base form
will be equal to 100 minus nine point
one percent which will be ninety point
nine percent right or you could just set
it up the same way we did it here except
instead of putting the number of acids
on top you would put the number of base
the bottom would still be the total
right and I'll note that here right this
is the here is the total right okay so
that's essentially it and the future
will we'll be doing is we'll you'll be
shown a particular order we asked about
a particular amino acid and you'll be
given the pKa of all three functional
groups if they're three there might be
two and you'll be expected to to draw
the amino acid at a particular pH given
its PKS
so I hope that video was helpful and
yeah I hope that video was helpful and
see you next time
oops